threat of checkmate white's queen trying
to bring itself up across
and trap the black king magnus going in
desperation mode sacrificing his bishop
he's currently a whole rook down his
only saving grace is that he can check
the white king a few times
with his queen nakamura all he needs to
do is find a safe haven for that king
it's not easy but it should be possible
um even with 20 seconds on the clock i
think he can just take that bishop okay
he moves his king
instead and that's nice that's really
nice protecting the white rook
yeah it kind of it kills the checks
completely you don't have to do any
calculation whatsoever
he's uh well magnus is insistent
he really wants to get those checks
because it's the only way he's going to
save his
uh magnus is about to resign the white
king running away to safety on the left
side
hikaru wins it's over hikaru nakamura
winning the first game in the second day
of
finals making a huge comeback and this
means drama if
they now tie